this next story almost doesn't even
require doing because it's so obvious
and it has always been obvious but
Republican Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell is now saying that even though
he said it would have been wrong to fill
a Supreme Court seat during Barack
Obama's last year of his second term
back in 2016 he actually would fill a
hypothetical Supreme Court opening next
year 2020 which by the way is the last
year of Donald Trump's presidential term
he would not suggest if there is a
vacancy next year that we wait for the
results of the 20/20 election so that we
can let voters have a say in the
direction that they want the Supreme
Court to go in words almost don't even
have the ability to express the brazen
and sort of vile political nature of
this entire conversation but I do think
we should have the discussion so we can
file it and refer back to it when we
need to in the future and I'm sure that
we're going to need to refer back to it
in the future so remember that back in
2016
right-wing Supreme Court Justice Antonin
Scalia died this created a vacancy on
the Supreme Court Barack Obama was the
president at the time and Barack Obama
nominated Merrick garland now Merrick
garland was no far-left guy he was a
centrist jurist and completely
uncontroversial in relation to the
status quo anyway in basically every way
the Senate has to confirm Supreme Court
nominees Mitch McConnell was in charge
of the Senate in the same way that he's
in charge now and Mitch McConnell
blocked it they never even had
confirmation hearings for Merrick
garland McConnell at the time said well
you know it's the last year of Barack
Obama's term we don't know if the
Democrat or Republican is going to win
in November of 2016 so it would be
appropriate before we take up any
nominations for the Supreme Court we
should let voters have a say about the
direction they want the country going
and let the winner of the 2016 election
choose Anthon in Scalia's replacement
now we knew that it was horse manure
back then presidents or presidents for
the
for years of their term the last year is
just one of the four years of those four
year terms and there is plenty of
historical precedent for Supreme Court
confirmations in the fourth year of a
president's term we knew at the time if
it was a Republican president in 2016
if the nomination had been to replace
Antonin Scalia with a right-wing judge
selected by a Republican president Mitch
McConnell would have immediately held
those confirmation hearings they would
have filled the seat and that would have
been in now at a Kentucky local Chamber
of Commerce event Mitch McConnell was
asked this was yesterday or the day
before someone in the audience said
should a Supreme Court seat become
available next year in 2020 what is your
position going to be about filling that
spot meaning 2020 is the going to be the
last year of Donald Trump's term you
said back in 2016 no Supreme Court
confirmations in the last year of a
presidential term what happens if the
same situation comes up in 2020 and
McConnell simply says after sipping his
iced tea during the event oh well we
would just fill it check out the video
online I don't want to play it because
it's from a local news station and even
though I know that it would be well
within our fair use rights to play the
video local news stations are insanely
aggressive with their copyright claims
and I just don't want to deal with it
because it's bad for the show but what
he said is oh we would fill that seat
now if you really want to see the deep
depths of this sort of post hoc logic
that these Republicans are applying just
listen to the explanation that was given
by Mitch McConnell spokesperson for this
double-standard media outlets rightly
went to Mitch McConnell's office and
they said hold on a second Mitch
McConnell did one thing during Barack
Obama's last year of his term and he
says that he's going to do something
totally different
hypothetically during the last year of
Donald Trump's term how does he explain
this obvious political gamesmanship and
David pop who is McConnell's
spokesperson
said nono there's a difference between
2016 and 2020 in 2016
Democrats had the White House but
Republicans had the Senate in 2020
Republicans will have the White House
and Republicans will also have the
Senate that is not an explanation or in
a sense like it's an explanation but
what he's saying is oh the reason that
we would do it differently in 2020 than
2016 is because we can and we control
not only the Senate but also the White
House so it's likely that we would be in
favor of whoever Donald Trump would
nominate in 2020 but the sickest part of
it is that the entire room or a lot of
it laughed when Mitch McConnell said oh
we would seat we would confirm that
person they're all in on the joke like
it's not even something that they're
hiding everybody knew in 2016 that
McConnell's explanation was a dishonest
one and we knew that if the same thing
happened under a Republican president
they would just confirm the Supreme
Court pick and lots of Americans I mean
Republicans - they all understood that
that was the game being played and
they're fine with it like it's some kind
of funny joke and meanwhile remember
those people who in the lead-up to the
2016 election people on the Left we're
saying if it's not whoever I really want
I don't care if it's Hillary or Trump
it's basically the same thing if it's
Hillary or Trump Trump Supreme Court
picks tell us why it's not the same and
we will now have a conservative Supreme
Court for a long time an even longer
time if Donald Trump gets reelected in
2020 and this is where this is why
Republicans are winning on the issue of
the courts Republicans decades ago
decided they recognized the importance
of the courts and they realized whether
it's the Supreme Court whether it's
federal judges whatever we need to focus
on this and the Republican Party has
focused on it and they're winning hugely
on it and when you have a contingent of
the left which said supreme court who
cares Hillary trombe ah they're both
just too centrist for me they're both
too much to the right for me I don't
care this is the result okay
the bed has been made and now we're
sleeping in it
and mostly it's the blame of the right
but there's a little bit of the left
that also has to take some of the blame
here and this is exactly the result that
we predicted let's hope that Donald
Trump doesn't get a Supreme Court
vacancy to fill next year and then let's
hope that someone else has voted in in
November of 2020 make sure you're
following the show on Instagram where we
will be polling the audience on an issue
related to the Supreme Court
instagram.com slash david pakman show
and while you're there follow me as well
I'm David Pakman on Instagram